magic mushrooms are going to be
decreased in Denver voters electing to
make the city the first we becoming
first city in America to decriminalize
magic mushrooms on May 7th 2019 Denver
voted to become the first city in
America to decriminalize magic mushrooms
on the night of the victory
campaign organizer Kevin Matthews
announced that he was taking the
movement nationwide for our success
tonight will be a signal to the rest of
the country that these kinds of
campaigns are viable that if individuals
choose to unite behind the idea of
changing the laws around psilocybin it
can happen a few weeks later Oakland
decriminalized all psychedelic plants
and fungus that motion passes
unanimously
Santa Cruz California followed in
Oakland's footsteps on January 29th and
now statewide efforts are underway in
Washington State Oregon and California
when it comes to psychedelics we feel
people should have the freedom of choice
to choose what they want and in essence
cognitive Liberty Ryan Dunn 'var is the
head of decriminalize California which
is looking to take the movement one step
further the group seeks to convince
California voters not only to eliminate
laws that prohibit the possession and
consumption of psychedelic mushrooms but
to create a legal framework for
commercial sales we realized all right
let's make sure nobody else goes to jail
for this let's give it a proper
regulated system and let's make sure
nobody creates a Bureau cannabis
controlled model for mushrooms because
that'll just screw up everything and we
realized in order to do that you
actually have to in essence legalize
sales
but done a verse approach is proving
controversial within the movement among
those who seek decriminalization as a
path to communing with nature we led
from a place of love that is we didn't
push commodification we pushed equitable
access and just decriminalizing our
relationship with nature
Carlos plays Ola is the head of
decriminalized nature in Auckland which
is geared towards removing barriers for
city residents who want to exercise the
right to experience these naturally
occurring substances the city basically
said we recognize the healing effect of
these plants so the citizenry hears that
and says oh I'm curious now and because
it's sanctioned people are stepping into
those healing spaces with less fear
which leads to less bad trips plays Ola
veteran political operative in Auckland
runs his operation out of the Haven a
community center that serves as a hub
where members of the Bay Area's
psychedelic community gather to share
their experiences and what have become
known as integrative circles such as
this one hosted by the LA based group
psychedelia integration people come and
talk about their psychedelic experiences
and unpack them in a supportive group
setting Danyelle Negron of san francisco
psychedelic society says these
gatherings are a place for those who've
had intense psychedelic trips to talk
with others and to share information
about their use in therapy and in
treating addiction sometimes these
experiences can really transform a
person change them open up their mind in
ways they had never accessed before we
provide community and connection and
support for people so that they can go
through these experiences knowing that
they're not alone decolonization is a
risk reduction strategy we're allowing a
space for people to come together we're
allowing people to feel less concerned
about the risk that might be for coming
out Larry Norris runs Eyrie another
group that facilitates integration
circles and says the decriminalization
movement is just getting started and
that he favors it over legalization in
which case the state would need to
create a regulatory framework an
inalienable right to have our own
relationship to make sure there's no
reason for us to have to you know go to
dispensary or go to a pharmaceutical
company to get the things that we can
grow into the ground
my concern is to what degree will it
attract the attention
of individuals who maybe would not have
been drawn to take a psychedelic but who
with all the media play and the cultural
Rumble about this figure that they could
try it but don't understand how to
optimally structure the experience
Charles Grove is the director of
adolescence and child psychiatry at UCLA
Harborside and co-author of landmark
study involving the dosing of terminal
cancer patients with psilocybin he wants
psychedelics to be used primarily in
clinical settings for now
what we observe with this study was that
our subjects to begin with we're in
great existential crisis their sense of
self had eroded the sense of continuity
over time often a sense of loss of
meaning loss of purpose what we found
with these psychedelic experiences
individuals reported they were often
able to re-establish that sense of self
continuity with the previous parts of
their lives and strengthen their sense
of meaning and purpose
Grob is one of many scientists working
in the field of psychedelic research
which has experienced several
breakthroughs in recent years thanks to
the decades-long effort of the
multidisciplinary Association of
psychedelic studies or Maps Maps has
funded studies treating PTSD and
veterans with MDMA commonly known as
ecstasy the results were so promising
the FDA designated it a breakthrough
therapy fast-tracking the approval
process so that the treatment could be
available by as early as 2021 pending
completion of phase 3 clinical trials
Grob was inspired to become a doctor and
rolling in med school in the 70s after
discovering the work of early
psychedelic researchers while working
the night shift at a lab when
psychedelics were first discovered in
the early 40s and then really
distributed to psychiatrists around the
world in the 50s it quickly became
apparent the psychedelics had the
potential to become the cutting edge of
psychiatric research much of the
original discoveries of particular major
neurotransmitter systems in the brain
came from preclinical research with
psychedelics what I found even of
greater interest and even importance was
the use of LSD and other psychedelics
particularly psilocybin to treat their
psychiatric disorders that did not
respond well to conventional treatments
there were outstanding results reported
from several studies designed to treat
chronic alcohol abusers finding that
even with one treatment session with a
psychedelic well was sometimes a brief
psychotherapy individuals would have
dramatic remission of their severe
disorder and simply stop drinking it was
noted that the best outcomes for those
individuals who had what was described
as a powerful mystical level experience
a powerful psycho-spiritual epiphany so
in a sense the mystical memetic
properties of these drugs were a highly
unusual but Grove is wary of making them
available to the public without guidance
from experienced professionals in a
clinical setting nothing is without risk
and some individuals are going to be a
greater risk than others I've published
a paper on potential adverse
interactions between SSRI
antidepressants and ayahuasca some
individuals have some underlying risk
for psychotic illness whether it's
schizophrenia more than black polar
spectrum the experience particularly
under adverse conditions may push them
over the edge into a psychotic State
people really should be and should
understand they need to be in a very
quiet setting you know ideally out in
nature but protected so you're with
someone at all times who is not tripping
but done avert worries that legalizing
only medical use will mean that many
people who could benefit from
psychedelics won't have access to go
through a psychedelic assisted
experience the cost can be anywhere
between like two thousand five hundred
to seven thousand dollars which means
basically only rich white people would
be able to use it this is a People's
Movement and the FDA trials no help so
very small percentage of people and
there's a much broader range of people
who maybe can't get into the cultural
ethos of a clinical system maybe can't
afford a clinical system so the concern
around unleashing these medicines and a
non-professional
a non controlled setting it's already
happening and it's been happening for
thousands of years people have been
working with psychedelics and healing
with these medicines are we gonna accept
that that's happening or are we going to
ignore that that's happening keep in
mind that when they've been used since
time immemorial by indigenous peoples
there was a long record of use always
within the context of ritual ceremony
they were not recreational compounds
they were not taken with alcohol we live
in a very different culture where all
bets are off
as for the effort to fully legalize
psychedelics in California the Attorney
General's Office approved the
initiatives language in early January
and the campaign is currently collecting
the six hundred twenty-five thousand
signatures it needs to qualify for the
ballot this thing is won or lost in the
next five months as it is my hope for
the next five years for the
decolonization movement is that it's an
international movement that it's being
talked about at the United Nations that
every country in the world is having
this conversation they never should have
been made illegal to begin with nor
should any relationship between humans
and nature be made illegal
you